pues es importante porque Estados Unidos
quiere cambiar la forma como Estados
Unidos y el continente africano sean
relacionados económicamente los años
pasados el mensaje de de Joe biden el
presidente es de que los países
africanos dejen simplemente de ser
receptores de ayuda y empiecen a ser
socios comerciales en ese sentido pues
eh resaltó que se hizo un memorando de
entendimiento con los países africanos
para crear un nuevo una nueva área de
libre comercio continental en África
también se comprometió para con un pacto
para facilitar el comercio entre países
africanos Y en este sentido dijo que era
muy importante precisamente la inversión
en infraestructura Se comprometió de
hecho a través de inversión privada a
pues 350 millones de dólares
precisamente para fomentar esa
infraestructura en los países africanos
que permita ese intercambio comercial en
África entre países africanos también se
comprometió ya finalizando intervención
en 800 millones de dólares más para la
seguridad cibernética resaltó mucho que
es importante que los países africanos
tengan mejor acceso a las tecnologías y
precisamente a un internet más seguro
para tener mejor conectividad
Cristóbal el enfoque de hoy en la Cumbre
ha sido el desarrollo empresarial a ese
respecto cuéntenos qué dijo Antonio
blinquen el secretario de estado
en una breve intervención al frente de
grandes empresarios africanos pues
resaltó varios puntos primero que pues
quiere que las embajadas estadounidenses
en países africanos tengan un desarrollo
tengan una sección económica mucho más
presente que tengan muchas más
actividades mucha más reuniones con
líderes empresariales de la región
también dijo Jehová a dinamizar la
inversión de empresas privadas y de ongs
también en los países africanos sin
embargo Pues resaltó que retos retos por
ejemplo en los diferentes códigos
tributarios que tienen los países para
poder facilitar ese comercio reto sobre
todo en la infraestructura de estos
países de África que pues dificultan el
comercio no solamente en el Continente
sino del continente con otras regiones
sin embargo pues se mostró bastante
positivo de que se hicieran varios
negocios y que esta Cumbre salgan varios
negocios que ayuden al desarrollo del
continente africano